Celine Dion was leaving her hotel in New
York City when she was spotted in the
back of the car by fans one fan for you
to Solomon seize the moment and sang
slams hit I surrender and Celine stopped
the car Taba listen
do believe to me
you
bull move well good for her for shooting
her shot for we're getting out there and
go for it she's insane her pulse like if
my voice is a little shaky trying to do
that well not nervous she probably was
certificate having this moment like it
wasn't planned
no it was just like what happens to
sling Nelson says Slean made her day wow
this woman sounds great sin is betting
being respectful I just lost it
excuses love Queens lean for really
stopping connecting through music with
her fan at Christmases honey Celine was
being gracious to help because that was
terrible the second phase she made says
it all
okay all I'm saying people are having
some fun yet with this so yes but that's
become a meme that face of slean's so
people have been using it over the past
24 hours
take it for what you will some people
are seeing that she looks like what's
happening here so interpret it as you
want this is what people are doing
anything that I'm just saying I'm not
judging the performance in any way but
yes take yeah oh yeah I can't imagine
like the the pressure that girl that was
under that's something like she's cold
she's nervous yeah she has a great voice
but yeah hey if you're again like
shooting a shot like that I did she
expect that the car to stop did you
expect her to actually turn and give her
the time to listen you can't give up
what you can't you have to going no
matter how you feel like that's this is
happening in this moment whoever says
she looks amazing I think part of this
cuz she's wearing sunglasses so you
can't really read what's liens reaction
is I'm looking for her eyebrows like if
your eyebrows are way up there but then
they look pretty relaxed like it is a
very like stones very neutral yeah just
like anything excuses what doesn't mean
being used for it's just like more yeah
if you're reacting to something and kind
of like what's happening over there that
notices there's already a mean whistling
rolling out the window yeah I saw that
one someone's manipulated it's a bit of
like the blinking guy this one it's a
bit of like that right yeah I'm very
like video'll yeah okay Terry says
things class all the way no she is yeah